car il moqué noah au fait tu croyais
qu'elle n'entendra plus jamais parler de
cancer après sa double mastectomie
jusqu'à ce qu'elle voit en ligne de
témoignages inquiétants
puis en rappel de santé canada au sujet
des implants à surface texturée bio
celle 16 un plan comme des milliers
d'autres canadienne elle risque
maintenant de développer un autre cancer
le lymphome anaplasique à grandes
cellules
j'étais furieux parce que moi j'ai
enlevé mes c'est pour que je trompe pas
avec la transfère seulement d'avoir des
implants qui peut me donner le cancer un
cancer peut être moins rare qu'on ne le
croit les signalements du lymphome fait
à santé canada ont presque doublé depuis
l'été dernier passant de 54 rapport en
mai à 106 en décembre incluant des cas
non confirmée pour cette survivante du
lymphome
il ne s'agit plus d'un cancer rare mais
rarement diagnostiquée en raison d'un
manque d'éducation des spécialistes avec
une première conférence mondiale tenue à
rome cet automne la maladie attire
l'attention
plusieurs chercheurs y ont déploré le
manque de statistiques fiables selon eux
les risques de contracter le lymphome
sont plus élevés qu on le croit au
canada bon nombre de chirurgiens
plasticiens ont peu de réponses à donner
aux patientes inquiète mais ne
recommande pas de retirer les implants
sans diagnostic officiel du lymphome
pour karine meaux kenza howett
l'inquiétude était trop grande la mère
de deux enfants a déjà fait remplacer
ces implants même sans diagnostic
je ne veux pas prendre la rescousse et
c'est pas quelque chose que je peux
vivre avec
au québec le ministère de la santé et
des services sociaux a contacté près de
7500 tation portant des implants texture
et la vaste majorité de type bio celle
valérie wallet radio canada toronto